けんすうさん、他5名の新作が届きました
フォロー中のクリエイターの新作です！
けんすう
SNS x アテンション・エコノミーの時代から、生成エーアイが加わることで、アタッチメント・エコノミーの時代になる
落合陽一
考える文明から味わう文明へ——RAを雇うよりエーアイのほうが安い，という話から始めたい
緑色のドロドロだけは許せない——さよならホモ・サピエンスの前に
梶谷健人
多くの企業のエーアイ活用推進が失敗する真の理由は、人を崇高な存在だと過信しすぎていること
梅木 雄平
NOT A HOTELがシリーズDで100億調達など：ウメキワークスvol.475
しがらみ
朝の呟き　2026年8月7日　金
給与明細買取屋さん公式note
ケアマネ求人の中では高給だった中小企業に転職したケアマネジャの黒塗りなしバージョン
きょうのあなたにおすすめの記事が届いています！
BigShip |  ひとり法人2期目
中小企業診断士1次試験 2026 | 1点差で・・・
ひとりごと
中年独身男性、「世界一ゴキゲンなソロ生活」を攻略する
コンサル企業分析室
ベイカレント社員のリアルな評判｜口コミまとめ
課長になったSIer勤め人
黒字リストラと45歳の線引き
がむ27卒＠28卒向けやさしい就活
2002年、世界最大のIT企業が、BIG4の一角だった「PwCコンサルティング部門」を丸ごと買収したという事実を知っていますか。
IBMコンサルティングの知られざる出自｜コンサル就活ガイド
Daniel
エーアイでプログラミングが不要になる時代に、むしろ必要になるもの
おすすめの本を紹介しまくる人
【世界の裏ルール】超富裕層が仕掛ける合法的な国盗りゲーム『破壊系資本主義』が暴くサイテーな現実
のぞきち
【デロイト編】人事の言葉に化かされない！
グローバル決算報告で見る、企業の正体
ジェーティーシーで新規事業はむりむり🐌
【評価】短期で目立ったものが勝ちという不条理さ
吉永和貴（かず）
「死ぬ瞬間の5つの後悔」を読んで
もっと見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。